still we got some good hits in still we
got some good information
the best hits did come from cruz i don't
say that just because i'm friends with
the guy and i host a
a podcast with him he shines in these
moments and he cut to the
art of of the issue he had jack dorsey
this
creepy long-bearded nose ring-wearing
hipster ceo of twitter
who tried to kill the new york
post-hunter biden story
he had him in front of him and he said
jack
does twitter influence the political
elections very simple question does
twitter
influence the elections mr dorsey
does twitter have the ability to
influence elections
no
you don't believe twitter has any
ability to influence elections
no we are one part of a spectrum of
communication challenges that people
have
so you're testifying to this committee
right now that that twitter when it
silences people when it censors people
when it blocks political speech
that has no impact on elections people
people have choice of other
communication channels with women
not if they don't hear information if
you don't think you have the power to
influence
elections why do you block anything
uh well we have policies that are
focused on making sure that more voices
on the platform are possible
we see a lot of abuse and harassment
which ends up silencing people and
helping them leave from the platform
you can what a bogus non-answer jack
gives to that question you can really
see
how cruz is a master at this kind of
questioning i remember one time
he was grilling zuckerberg on the hill
and you saw cruz shine as a prosecutor
here
you saw him it was solicitor jenner
general in his
previous life before the senate and you
could see that shine
he lured zuckerberg in because i don't
remember the question say
um mark uh what color is the sky
ella sky is blue senator yeah and mark
uh two plus two what what does that
equal well that equals four senator why
did palmer lucky get
fired and he just he off-foots him a
little bit
palmer lucky was a ostensibly a
political firing because he was
conservative
and zuckerberg didn't have an answer for
it same thing here yes
does twitter influence the elections no
man
jack dorsey is this like ridiculous
hipster no not at all man
it doesn't influence the elections at
all no it has no no political effect
okay then why do you suppress the
political stories
oh whoops yeah i did just admit that i
did that
uh we suppress people's voices so you
can hear them better
and whatever non-answer that was then
because that was not sufficient cruz
ripped dorsey
mr dorsey who the hell elected
you and put you in charge of what the
media are allowed to report and what the
american people are allowed to hear
and why do you persist in behaving as a
democratic super pac silencing
views to the contrary of your political
beliefs let's give
uh mr dorsey uh a few seconds to answer
that and
then we'll have to conclude this one
this segment
well we're we're not doing that and this
is why i
opened um this hearing with calls for
more transparency we realize
we need to earn trust more we realize
that more accountability is needed to
show
our intentions and to show the outcomes
thank you so i
i hear the concerns and acknowledge them
but
we want to fix it with more transparency
but he's obviously not hearing the
concerns he's not answering the
questions
cruz raises a great point there are
still like three
bizarro freshman year libertarians who
say well guys come on twitter's a
private company
google's a private company first of all
like not really
and second of all they they control the
flow of information they control the
public sphere
which by the way they have gained access
to by fraud
they told people they were getting one
product and they actually gave them
another they got legal
liability protection through section 230
because they pretended to be one product
and actually
they were another this is a question
about you know the individual operations
of these businesses
or self-government and by the way no
grown man should have a nose ring i know
this seems tangential
we should pass a constitutional
amendment in this country
that grown men are not permitted to wear
nose rings
it is a national humiliation
particularly when coupled with that
beard
which should land jack dorsey on the
no-fly list
it wasn't only senator cruz who was
going after him
mike lee did a great job too mike lee
you know pretty
pretty hardcore guy he's brilliant at
constitutional law
mike lee first goes after mark
zuckerberg
and it was another one of these simple
questions that they couldn't answer we
know that many conservatives have been
censored we know a lot of conservative
stories have been censored so lee says
okay
you guys say it's not a partisan issue
it's not an ideological
issue can you name me one lib that's
been censored on your platforms
can you name for me one high-profile
person
or entity from a liberal ideology who
you have censored
and what particular action you took uh
senator i i can get you a a list of some
more of this but there are certainly
many examples that
your your democratic colleagues um
object to
when when um you know a checker might
label something as false that they
disagree with
or um they're not able to i get that
i get that i just want to be clear i'm
just asking if you can name
for me one high-profile liberal person
or company who you have sensitive i
understand that
you're saying that there are complaints
on both sides but i just i just want
one name of one person or one entity
um senator i need to i need to think
about it and and
and get you more of a list oh my gosh
it's so embarrassing zuckerberg
usually is a little quicker on his feet
than this because well look we have a
list we can get you more of a list
i guess no i don't you didn't give me
you didn't give me anything so you're
not giving me more of it you're giving
me anything at all but it's okay mark
you don't need to give me the full list
just name like one guy just one because
i could name a ton of conservative name
one guy
uh uh uh i i don't know so then lee
moves on he goes okay
jack dorsey same question to you name me
one liberal
who has been censored on your platform
uh what about you mr dorsey
well we we can give a more exhaustive
list
but again we don't have an understanding
of political action
of our accounts but i'm not asking for
an exhaustive list i'm asking for a
single example
one one individual one entity any one
we've we've taken action on tweets from
members of the house for election miss
info
can you identify any example yes with
two
two democratic um two two democratic uh
congress people
on a lot of their names so i'll get
those those names too
pathetic pathetic dorsey thought that he
like
he was anticipating this question or
he's just making it up on the spot
but assuming someone briefed him and
said look there actually there were a
couple times you took down a couple
tweets from democrats make sure you have
that in your head
no no we had some liberals yeah what are
their name well first he tries to say
we're unaware of the ideological views
of our users like oh really are you
you're unaware of what donald trump
thinks versus what aoc thinks but then
he contradicts himself and he says no
we yeah no we took down some liberals
yeah who
uh a couple democrats yeah what where
were they
uh they're congressmen yeah what are
their names
uh yeah no my boyfriend he lives in
canada he lives uh no you can't meet him
guys because he lives in canada i'm
starting to think
he doesn't exist i'm i've pretty much
had it with these tech guys but there
was one last moment that i think is
worth pointing out
marcia blackburn my new senator i'm
leaving
california i'm moving to tennessee i'm
very pleased to be trading kamala harris
for marcia blackburn marsha blackburn
does a great job and she did an
especially great job
yesterday during these hearings because
she caught
jack dorsey in a lie jack dorsey says
that he doesn't censor world leaders why
did he bring this up because
you've got tweets from the grand poobah
of iran
up of the the ayatollah that are vile
vicious tweets and he doesn't take those
down
so that's the rule right you're going to
take down the new york post but you're
going to leave up the ayatollah of iran
because you don't censor world leaders
problem is
jack has censored trump so
mr dorsey is donald trump a world leader
yes okay so it would be important for
world leaders to have
access to your platform correct
correct and so why did you deny that
platform via
censorship to the us president we
haven't censored the u.s president
oh yes you have how many posts from
iran's terrorist ayatollah have you
censored
how many posts from vladimir putin have
you censored
we have we have label tweets of world
leaders we have a policy around not
taking down the content
but simply having more context around it
okay
and the us president you have censored
65
times just to be clear we we have not
censored the president we have not
um taken the tweets down that you're
referencing um they have more context
than a label
uh applied to them and we do the same
for leaders around the world
so everything about that is a lie he
censored trump he censored trump
multiple times now what he's saying is
no all i did was block out what he
tweeted and then make you click through
to a separate page
so that you could see what he read
that's not censorship
yes it is that is censorship you don't
have to formally permanently delete
something
to censor it if you slap a big label
over it such that you can't read it
until you click through to another page
that is censorship and he has done that
to trump
then he tries to pretend that he's done
that to the other world leaders maybe he
has in some isolated cases
but not all the time not even in the
most egregious examples iran's
leader denies that the holocaust
happened says there there
was no holocaust he is called to wipe
israel off of the face of the earth
seems kind of violent to me
not only are those tweets still up
there's no extra context around that
jack dorsey and twitter have censored
trump much
much more significantly than they have
censored the leader of iran
i said that was the last one there's one
more i have to get to corey gardner
cory gardner also grylls elise
zuckerberg i think he was just glad to
be out of the line of fire he said yeah
okay you take it jack
jack dorsey just absolutely crumbled
under pressure and corey gardner
called him out for the double standard
so somebody denying the murder of
millions of people
or instigating violence against a
country as a head of state is not
categorically falling in any of those
three misinformation or other
categories twitter has not
misinformation but we do have other
policies
around incitement to violence which
which may
um some some of the tweets that you
mentioned or the examples that you're
mentioning
uh may fall follow um but for misleading
information uh we're focused on those
three categories only
so somebody denies the holocaust has
happened is not misinformation
it's it's misleading information but we
don't have a policy against that type of
misleading information we
millions of people died and that's not
a violation of twitter again i just
don't understand
how you can label a president of the
united states
have you ever taken a tweet down from
the i told him
so he crumbles and and cory gardner
points out this double standard
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts